services of general interest such as  water health social service and  education should be clearly out of the  remit of Teeter on investment protection  we've discussed it many times but the  red line for my group is not an investor  protection per se but the essence that  we must have the right to regulate  anything in an investment agreement that  limited the right to regulate would be  unacceptable  Johan visas are commissioned by ischemia  only hair stay long therefore Sengkang  hunts by McNamee steam been marked their  location unknown met him after coming  here with him XS T on us pin marks  because bunch also enough is familiar  CLE and Sentra that's really wasn't me  I'd become while you hold a foolish king  of the committee on aina posits you  informally album on the Masters venison  Vemma Mendez targets and abstinence egg  eaters from $252 20